on this episode the last seven minutes
dominate
[Music]
[Music]
Gary B everybody this is gary
vay-ner-chuk and this is the ascott83
off india listen me everybody this is
gary vay-ner-chuk and you're watching
nerd stuff and this is a 189 i'm yes
gary vee yeah and clearly we are in a
very we're clearly in book mode right
now this is the night before the big day
tomorrow it drops like it I was gonna
say like it's hot but I don't like that
it drops tomorrow I'm very very proud
the early reviews are in and it's widely
considered one of the great literally
example at a literally literally what is
it
literary examples of business in modern
time according to tomorrow Vaynerchuk
mother of Gary Vaynerchuk but more
importantly the vibes are good and we're
sitting here I'm going to be on CNN
tonight
so a lot of you can comment after that
aired and you can talk about that
I've got good day New York local New
York Fox tomorrow back to st. Louis
tomorrow night for a big event in st.
Louis than it Lanta then Boston then
Austin rhymed I'm feeling really good
India but this is 189 of the askgaryvee
show
that's the askgaryvee book do you love
the book yeah then you buy like 40
million did your mom and dad buy the
book my mom bought a book understand did
she like why are we making them wars
it's unfair
she's much cooler than you she is who
need her mom to sit here and take your
spot for an episode oh I'm so excited
that's alright India yeah here we go you
know it's funny I don't know if you've
seen this if started on the book tour
started and I've had a couple of people
last night did you see anybody do that
last night breathe air yeah we have to
do it with them on sell the show it's
cool
let's do it official right now 189 ready
let's do this show all right let's do it
I'm feeling good I feel like thing you
know couple people mention that this is
a new golden ear I do feel like the last
four or five been really tight I've been
Stefan I like that little head now that
means it's been tight if you look we
should do something special for the book
like if you buy one for Fred if you tag
somebody in the oh I like this tagging
idea especially enough yeah
especially in a Facebook game I know
some of you watching on YouTube but
we're gonna do something with it don't
let me forget actually let me do it
because I'll forget tag somebody that
you think is not aware of all of this
that should get the book and I'm gonna
pick five people cos Phi is my lucky
number of people that were tagged that
respond into the comments so you know
you tag somebody they jump into me like
what are you talking about Ricky
you know I will pick five of those
people that actually respond to the
tagging and send them assigned personal
copy to them now I know you're thinking
wait a minute but I love the show and I
want a personal well sometimes you need
to give you have to get Kyle Kyle Reed
asks how do you balance saying no to
good things so you can say yes to great
things
you know Kyle you're talking about
decision-making and time management and
opportunity costs as a tremendous
question you know who gets to decide
what is good or great is first and
foremost what may be good to me may not
be great to you like for me if I could
meet Ric Flair for dinner that would be
great for you know are you excited about
having dinner with Ric Flair yeah do you
know the raclette is exactly now named
one of your favorite bands oh I know
what am I really I don't know that it
the actor yeah I know this but no give
me a band that you love right hand
follow me just say it stop being scared
of some random want to describe so I
don't know anything about grabs I've
never heard of rhymes and you'd be like
hey we can get like the lead singer of
Grimes it's a singer email right now and
said I want to have dinner I'd be like
delete you know like I don't even know
right and so who gets decide what's good
and great and that's why I'm answering
this question with that little skit
which is you know you don't know until
you do it and so what's a Kyle Kyle too
many people are crippled by
this question I'm gonna get a serious
now for a second you don't know if
something's good or great until it
actually happens some of the greatest
things that have ever happened to me in
business look terrible on paper wasn't
somebody fancy was it fancy you know it
just was kind of like oh wait and that
person knew and then I connected and you
know meaning bling kook the original CTO
of Twitter for taco at South by
Southwest on the dawn of South by
Southwest this week well that didn't
look like the greatest meeting of my
life it turned into one of the greatest
meetings of my life like like there's
you know like this this happens all the
time and so you're too many people are
crippled by the right hire by the right
meeting I say work harder work more
efficient make more 15 and 30 minute
meetings that leave you more time to do
more things and create more
opportunities and don't be crippled by
choosing the right opportunities or not
so the answer is nobody can answer that
for you normally you can't answer it
upfront right like I did a bunch of
podcasts that I never heard of the
people before and I think some of them
have been paying dividends and I did a
podcast with Shaq that's gonna air
shortly on paper it looks like Shaq's
was a greater thing than good but I
think we're gonna sell more books from
some of that good cuz I didn't realize
the audience that person had be more
efficient with what you do to allow you
to do more things then you don't have to
worry about the subjective and non
controllable like knowing what's good or
great
that's the recap the Fanueil asks Gary
you've said YouTube Facebook Twitter
periscope and Instagram are the big
players what's your opinion on vine I
think vine has taken a secondary spot I
still think there's a real community
there I do think Instagram and snapchat
took a lot of those vine celebrities
there's still plenty of stuff going on
there I'm spending less time on there
I'm it's it's it's now in the Miche and
young category I look for mass and older
category that's where I'm betting on
those things that I've brought up so I
think that vine has a place I as I'm
talking right now I'm going to look up
where vine is in the in the rating
system right now in the App Store which
is always a great indicator on where
things are so you know
to me like I would rather pay attention
to what's going on with musically right
now by the way snapchat is number one of
social networks three games than
snapchat and Facebook messages and
Facebook than Instagram than YouTube the
next thing that pops up is Pinterest at
18 which is interesting whatsapp at 21
musically at 25 Twitter at 27 look at
that musically above Twitter and I keep
pushing musically in every was there not
kick very under the radar very big with
younger demo you know that's 34 as of
this moment right there's that wish app
that I've been telling people about
periscope at 49 RealPlayer they're right
where we go here we go here we go here
we go tender at 75 no vine yet by the
way in vines been slipping and I feel
like vines been and tumblers at 108 you
know I've been down on that group me at
122 LinkedIn at 140 no vine and so
that's that's kind of how I feel about
it
just looking yeah just a triple checking
here maybe I missed it because that can
be the case wheeze okay no bye so that's
you know go to categories real quick you
know so look I look at data and I you
know and I go by vibe and you know right
now in social networks is messenger you
know vine is is it even categorizing
this like yeah just there's time I gotta
find it can't be this slow so I don't
even know where it is right now I don't
know anyway that's how I think about in
India that's the bottom line
cool that's it go ahead
Benjamin bye where are you I feel like
I'm missing it's an out I play it
there's lime hey Gary Benjamin Grenier
you said you wanted some more
interesting videos for the show so I
went by this busy street in the big city
you wanted to ask a question the
question is how do you feel about
employee poaching taking employees from
somebody else's company
and bringing them to work for you good
bad or indifferent thanks Gary yeah I
think this is a very easy question
answer I think people hire from other
people's companies all the time I mean
it's this is you know this isn't this is
a nursery school it was a business and
if you if you can steal somebody from
another competitor or another company
that you think brings benefit to your
company and you've got recruiters and
then we have seventy nine ten full-time
recruiter in our media they're just
pounding hitting it and trying to find
the right people for us so I think in
big business this is just part of the
equation
poaching poaching makes it seem bad you
mean employee recruitment like I mean
you guys I mean I'm sure you're getting
emails from recruiters from LinkedIn all
the time right yeah I mean it happens
all the time
that's why I try to build it really I'm
very proud of our turnover voluntary
turnover here is incredibly low and that
means we're building culture means
people believe in me as a CEO believe in
Vayner and so you need to focus on
building a good business so people are
UNPO chable as you say but I think
that's common practice I don't think
there's anything you know I mean if
there's shady practices where people are
under contract or but normal everyday
like recruiters trying to find people
for jobs my thing that's I mean that's
like asking like what do you think about
having an accounting department or like
what do you think about having an office
for your business like that's that's
table stakes
that's oxygen that's normal business
behavior so I think you're alluding to
something that I guess ly lends itself
for so I love how you hacked the video I
guess it's lending itself to like hey
you stole my developer or you stole my
CTO will build a great product so
nobody's stealable build a great culture
so nobody's stealable like you know I
don't own India right like this is
voluntary an employer like like you know
like build something great that people
want to be a part of you want to be a
part of this India Cassandra why did
that what was why did that happen okay
so [ __ ] the new my book unbelievable
can you believe Stephane you didn't buy
a book either oh my god I saw it
directly in your face guys can you
please buy one copy tomorrow that
wouldn't matter to me
tomorrow's a big day tomorrow's a big
day we're like you know I did the three
book giveaway and in the Super eight we
did three book giveaway which gonna be
exciting everybody took advantage of
that an Instagram made the right
decision cuz that $55 is gonna turn out
to be gold but tomorrow's a big day to
me tomorrow tomorrow's a day it's a
release day above and beyond I'm asking
I'm gonna hit up everybody I know on my
flight to st. Louis and be like just one
one just one tonight
like can I can I count on you guys for
one copy now here's the real quick
question can I count on you for one copy
from like a random friend which mean
you'd be in for two yeah like like well
yeah I mean I don't want to spend your
money could you convince somebody to buy
a copy for themselves cuz I'll be good
for them yeah all right you felt very
confident you felt Shady do you think
they bought a book yet no yeah what
please okay yeah Cassandra alright let's
remember that any time we have a Kasane
zone we do that Cassandra Cassandra asks
I read somewhere that being nervous is a
good thing
do you agree or disagree do you ever get
nervous sure I get nervous I mean
everybody gets nervous I get nervous not
that often because I'm not putting
myself in nervous positions anymore you
know I don't have to feel nervous about
like hitting on a girl anymore I don't
jump out of planes that would make me
very nervous trying to think alas time I
was like nervous like maybe a Heights
thing I'm trying to think even that I've
gotten better about oh did I say they
can snake that scared me I think I saw a
snake somewhere like a big snake in my
pants cart no ah I'll tell you what
makes me nervous I don't know if it's
nervous like when I see Xander almost
falling and hitting his head on a rock
is that nervous or am I like scared for
what is that yeah that's a yes it's a
nervous like a consistent nervousness I
don't I don't get nervous before I speak
or do TV
always nervous about like kid stuff
here's like yeah that's right right
I don't know I mean nervous is is a
trait people should get nervous I don't
get I believe that you do not get
nervous you know I get alert a weird
nervous energy before I speak or go on
TV but it's not I'm not nervous I'm so
jazzed up that I feel like insane right
so it feel it's like a cousin of nervous
like that moment but that I feel like if
you're like a competitor like you're
just gonna get that feeling like I'm
really nervous when we're shooting four
five on five yet the why I'm like I
really want
I really hope AJ's on my team because I
might get nervous that we get into a
fight today if we're on opposite teams
like I don't tend to get nervous and I
think if you're alluding this is a
business show kind of thing so if you're
asking about like nervous and I think
being nervous in a business environment
is a bad sign I do I do think that means
you're not prepare to means you know
have it yeah that it factor
I do think you have interesting energy
nervous energy but like flat-out nervous
I think is a tail is a tell that you
don't have a list stuff that being said
some of you may be nervous and then
crush it every time I have a little bit
like I don't want to call nervous
because not it's like it's adrenaline
but uh you know I don't think nervous is
back look I don't think any emotion is
bad I think it's human you know fear
look I do I think like like anger or
cynicism are there things that I don't I
don't appreciate or I think are a waste
of good energy sure but I don't think
any of them bad they're just natural
world human we've all got our stuff you
know that was it wow really wow look at
this hey Gary its Eric and Dave Wroten
from Arizona
hey Gary father and son we do we have a
YouTube channel where we teach people
how to make signs like this we've got
over 300 videos we close six videos a
week the name may sound familiar because
I got 10 signed books from you on the
super
five minutes in you pulled my name and
almost threw it back in the in the bin
but thank you for not I appreciate that
thank you for all you do our question to
you is we're all over Facebook we post a
facebook six times a week and we I'm
using Facebook dark posts so we're
getting really good reaction there but
we want to grow our brand we want to
grow our name grow our audience what
platform do you think is best to go to
next our demographic is somewhere
between 45 to 65 years old and
woodworkers obviously people that are
interested in woodworking so if you can
tell me tell us the next platform that
we should go into that's really what
we're looking for
appreciate your time Gary thanks for all
of the great stuff love you man
we'll see you later back here bye that
was so awesome
that was awesome what are the names
again David look I think when I was
looking I was kind of like India saw me
I was looking at your YouTube data kind
of making some assumptions on your
facebook data I think that everybody
this is great this is a great question
because I can answer for so many of you
everybody's looking for the next thing
before they've really won the last thing
I think is a lot of work to be done guys
on your let me give you a huge piece of
advice I would make those signs you
should here's what I'd like you to do
I'm gonna give some real tangible advice
right now so there's a channel so Dave
what I'd like you to do is I'd like you
to make these amazing signs for 50 to
100 influencers on YouTube I want you to
make these amazing signs for fifty to a
hundred of these other YouTube
influencers look what you did here you
just got exposure on a bigger YouTube
channel by asking this question you're
hacking worry I would actually rather
you cut down from six episodes a week to
three and take all that energy and time
and email out search here for whatever
the genre your think world is and reach
out to all these other hundreds of
thousands of YouTube providers that are
producing great content that might be in
your demo and don't go for Michelle Phan
like the billion people go for people
that have a hundred thousand subscribers
two hundred thousand subscribers they
haven't made it big yet and reach out
and say look I'd love to make a sign for
for around your logo or your YouTube
show baby pump this is looks incredibly
these guys are clearly good at what they
do and so what you need to do is more
collabo the real thing that people are
missing is collabo like there's a lot
if I was on dj khaled snapchat right now
do a big shout out to my boy Gary Vee
that's another change I would grow a
hundred thousand two hundred thousand
followers in a heartbeat ads are great
and you should definitely do them but
collabo collaborations for you all of
you at home are very very very important
I think you were actually making stuff
so you can bring something a real
handcraft work and a bunch of people
like forget you guys I don't care a
cowboy but one out of every 50 people
that you email it's gonna say that's
cool I want that then we're gonna give
you a shout out under two hundred
thousand person again
cowboy show you know sign show or just
kids like it could be anything and
that's gonna get you much better ROI I
would cut down the shows from 6 to 3
this is actually tremendous advice for
so many people cut down on the content
creation and start working on
distribution distribution my friends
collabo and dist oh nothing to work but
collaborations and distribution you need
more awareness what you did by getting
on this show by grabbing India's heart
was an absolute victory for you because
there are absolutely 5,500 people who
are watching right now they're gonna
subscribe to your channel follow you by
a sign or whatever your KPI is you need
more distribution and awareness not more
content not the next platform Facebook
and YouTube is exactly right for you
guys you just need to change your
behavior to respect collaborations which
are a gateway drug to distribution you
need more awareness within that
ecosystem that's what you need to be
doing it's a good advice to end the show
feels really good that's a very good way
Stefan we're gonna try to sneak in a
show tomorrow yeah in the morning 10:00
a.m. guys tomorrow hopefully I'll be
able to put out a show I'm a little
worried that it's gonna be the big day
and things might get tight and crammed
ly in this and that so if I don't get a
show in tomorrow 190 which i think is
remember I wanted 200 to be the show
that was gonna be the day of the book
and then
sense cuz we definitely slowed down and
daily be stuff and all this but um you
know what I'll just do it right now
because I don't wanna take the chance I
wanna take a moment in closing to thank
you guys all so much I guess
eighteen months ago or so maybe maybe
almost two years ago we started on this
journey around the askgaryvee concept
and here we are on the dawn of the book
coming out in so much momentum and so
much love and I just thank all of you so
much tomorrow's a very big day for me
and I I've so enjoyed everything I've
been providing to you guys as a
community and so and very honestly and
you may know this about me some of you
really know this about me I'm weirdly
very excited to get into May first where
I'm kind of out of this right-hook zone
I really want to take a second to thank
all of you for allowing me giving me the
permission to throw my right hook to
have your support to ask me for eight
books you know of the same book yes I'm
the same but you know like you know like
I really appreciate this moment that
you've given me to kind of you know at
least ask for the cash in against all
the upfront value I'm really looking
forward to getting another backend the
other thing is stuff I want you put it
up here everybody and this is probably
my biggest ass sure I would tell you I
have a 1a and 1b for tomorrow 1a would
be one more copy because I want the
momentum and like spiking to number one
and Amazon would be amazing and it comes
from volume not from quantity so anybody
that you know that needs this book
tomorrow's a day of like you've already
committed so many books tomorrow's a day
of you know you know say to one per just
like I waited with you to just one
person if all of you get one person to
mind just one book it's it changes a lot
for me but the one being is and put it
up here Stefan link it please and
Facebook in YouTube and don't forget
I'll get really pissed is the
garyvaynerchuk.com slash book review
everybody who has an Instagram I have a
page on my dot-com showing how I want an
Instagram review which is not a shout
out like I got it it's awesome know when
you read it to leave a long review on
Instagram with a photo that would really
mean a lot to me doesn't cost you
anything above and beyond would mean a
lot to me I'm really curious about I
think it's the right execution I think
the attention sits on Instagram and so
that's my 1a and 1b thank you so much
for your attention which is the asset
thank you so much to everybody that came
out last night in New York City six
hundred strong and the 92nd Street Y
Stephanie ruhle
you crushed it I enjoyed staying for two
hours doing all those selfies and book
signings I'm looking forward to doing
that in Atlanta st. Louis Boston and
Austin this week alone many more in the
future and so big ups Dublin and and
London and Sydney you got a lot of stuff
coming up really excited to meet so many
of you thank you so much for the love
this is an exciting journey and tomorrow
starts the next chapter of this journey
so thank you
question of the day question of day is
you know what I was gonna say we're
gonna do one aim one B that's too
self-serving let's go a different
direction question day what's your kind
of story
actually I need something to read like
to like on that 24 hours to each way to
Sydney what's your story
what's your askgaryvee story what's your
story what's your kind of story on this
journey together maybe a micro story
from episode 109 the collective of like
maybe you want to write it from one day
I stumbled maybe it's you know beginning
a lot of emails from people getting
results what's your story from this
whole askgaryvee experiment you keep
asking questions I'll keep answering
them
[Music]